we were talking about transitions a
moment ago so i wanted to hold off
because we have a story here actually
this is a tweet from colin wright good
friend of the show and it's actually
just a repost of an instagram post from
a female amateur skateboarder
he says female skateboarder taylor
silverman is speaking out after placing
second to a male competitor who
identifies as a woman at the red bull
cornerstone contest silverman and other
female skateboarders were robbed of
their achievements and prize money that
was meant for women in the post made on
instagram taylor silverman said my name
is taylor silverman i am a female
athlete i've been skateboarding for 11
years and competing for several years i
have been in three different contests
with trans women two of which i placed
second and the last contest series i did
for red bull i placed second the trans
competitor who won took a thousand
dollars in the qualifiers three thousand
dollars in finals and one thousand
dollars in best trick this totaled five
thousand dollars of the prize money
meant for female athletes i took one
thousand dollars in qualifiers in 1750
for second place so 2 750 in total the
girl who took third received 7.50 the
girl who deserved a thousand for best
truck best trick took nothing along with
whoever would have placed third i
deserved to place first be acknowledged
for my win and get paid i reached out to
red bull and was ignored i am sick of
being bullied into silence
in the next post
taylor silverman posted the email sent
to red bull saying hope all is well with
you i am reaching out in hopes of being
directed to the right person to express
my concerns about what occurred at the
red bull cornerstone contest with the
transgender competitor in the women's
division perhaps that is you if not
hopefully you can put me in contact with
the correct person a biological man with
a clear advantage won the women's
division best trick and also multiple
qualifiers this took away the
opportunity that was meant for women to
place and earn money what happened was
unfair and at the time i was too
uncomfortable to speak up i understand
that in today's society even some women
think this is acceptable but i believe
in doing the right thing even if it's
not the popular thing i now realize it's
really important for me to speak up and
i'd like to schedule a time to talk
so i have announced
that uh i got my math wrong but uh i
have announced i said tim cass will
gladly cover the difference and grant
taylor silverman the 2 250 difference
lost to placing behind a male athlete we
will also be willing to cover the total
total loss revenue for the female
athletes who would have placed higher
were it not for the male athlete now she
didn't lose 22.50
she lost 12.50 because she didn't win
best tricks someone else i guess you
said would have
and so
the so some people have asked me they
said you know tim you you you said that
the ncaa women you know it's too bad for
them or whatever i was like no no hold
on what i said you mean the swimming the
swimming
uh i said they are not complaining about
it how can i speak up for them if
they're not speaking out for themselves
taylor silverman spoke up for herself
said i don't believe this is fair and i
believe that's that's deserving of
support
and also totally biased i've been
skateboarding my whole life i i had
worked with the organization briefly
mind you that actually got equal pay for
women at the x games we've talked about
it quite a bit
when i saw this
knowing what i know from skateboarding
for
what am i going on 23 years knowing
about the physical elements knowing
about the physics
taylor silverman is absolutely correct
and let me make this point before we get
into the bigger picture
some people have said
uh in response to me we had our good
friend the amazing atheist said women
should compete in the women's division
i responded to colin wright saying that
men
males have a higher center of gravity
what this means is that from a standing
position a man can ollie higher a male
can ollie higher than a female females
carry their center of gravity lower
which is better for balance in a lot of
ways but means their their ali height
their jump height will be lower there
are very clear differences and
advantages that males will have
regardless of hormone replacement
therapy skateboarding is not a
muscle-based sport where it's like the
stronger you are the better you can be
there's there's aggress aggression
there's grit like your willingness to
take risks and it's very much control
if you have a higher center of gravity
you're going to be able to clear higher
obstacles
women also have what's called a more
pronounced q angle that's the quadricep
angle meaning because of the wide hips
the femur and the quadriceps come at a
harsher angle than a male would
regardless of hormone replacement
therapy this means that biological
females competing at any stage are going
to be higher more prone to leg injuries
knee injuries ankle injuries a clear
advantage for male athletes regardless
of if they're transitioning or not so
this one to me i think needs you know
i'm biased obviously but also
it's gone the story's gone viral
everybody's talking about it
um i think it's important to talk about
and i think it's important that people
like taylor silverman are speaking out
and saying you know i think this is not
fair now the crazy element is
her post on instagram has something like
unless i check 11 000 comments yeah it's
huge the anti-semitism mm-hmm because uh
taylor silverman is jewish right crazy
crazy and she has a star of david in her
right and these are these are the
leftists who hate israel who believe in
these weird conspiracy theories like
like the farrakhan stuff and are now
going after her and attacking her for
being jewish
simply because she said
this is money that was meant for female
athletes yeah i mean look the left
doesn't care about these things that
they claim to when they talk about like
racism sexism homophobia in fact despite
the vitriol they don't even really care
about the transgender issue they just
try to use these labels to accuse anyone
they think it would be useful to get out
of the public discussion
and
when it comes to their attacks on other
people they're almost always willing to
resort to these labels but it's never
talked about right so it's an instance
of
creating a rule surrounding certain
language about ethnicities like slurs
and then saying we are only going to
prosecute one group of people for doing
this so people on the left can get away
with it like crazy
i think they also wanted to figure out
how to make sure that white men could be
qualified as diversity hires
i think stories like these are the
biggest threat to so-called trans rights
because at this point when you get into
the sports and physically comparing the
two it's unavoidable so i know for a lot
of people they think live and let live
if somebody's above 18 let them go
through the process if they want to get
these plastic surgeries to make them
look like the opposite sex fine it's not
hurting anybody but then once you get to
down to something like a competition
where the differences are obvious we're
going to be seeing more and more cases
like this well and like leah thomas and
women's women's rights activists know
about this women's rights rights
activists can clearly see
um that showing the unfairness of men
competing against women in women's
sports could be the turning point needed
i want to give a shout out real quick to
uh to taylor silverman you can follow
her on instagram
taylormaysilverman and i'm and on
twitter i believe uh her twitter is t.m
silverman but specifically because she
posted on instagram this truth sounds
like hate to those who hate the truth
many people her position didn't stan
like for the league thomas there was no
woman who actually stood up only the one
who lost
yeah after she yeah so she so this is
another interesting thing uh taylor
spoke up um i believe in a few months
since the event
and i actually talked to her where were
maybe working something out uh some kind
of you know we'll do an interview or
maybe but um it's been a few months
actually since the contest and i looked
at her record
she's somebody who actually won actually
got cash she got second place you know
she qualifies she's winning when it came
to the ncaa swim meet the only person
who spoke up was the one who got bumped
like in eighth place or whatever it was
yeah it was like was it 17th or
something 16th place or something by the
way i made a decision and it wasn't even
her it was actually her teammate who
spoke up on her behalf oh wow i am going
to start calling all of the people who
want men dressed as women to compete in
women's sports men's rights activists
they are men they are there you are if
you say that
trans woman should be able to compete in
women's sports you are an mra and you
will be adopting the language of radical
feminists when you do it and
bravo look when women talk i listen
didn't we talk to vosh about that i
don't know yeah i'm pretty sure we
talked about men's rights activism i
said i said i said i don't i don't care
for using the word men or women i'll
just say mail so when i when i tweeted
this we had uh uh was t.j kirk is his
name right the amazing atheist yeah tj
kirk he said uh women should compete in
the women's division mm-hmm and then i
it's it's it's absurd to me
that
you're having a semantic argument for
what reason did we create women's
division sports was it because sometimes
people wear dresses
no it's because there are biological
differences to a great 90 of the time to
a great degree
between males and females and the
colloquial understanding in human
society was that man and woman meant
male and female in fact the mo to most
people today it still does so when
someone says a trans woman is a woman
therefore should compete in the women's
division it's like
we didn't create the women's division
based on the clothing you wear no
we didn't create the women's division
based on how you felt that day like oh
today i've decided i mean what if
someone's gender fluid and i'm serious
that's not just like a dunk on the lips
what if someone is gender fluid on the
day they feel like a woman do they
compete in the women's division
the answer would be yes there is
actually a ceo in the uk who
um makes 70 uh cents less per dollar
when when they identify as a woman
in fact there's i believe the ceo who is
gender fluid and some days wears uh
pencil skirts and some days wears
trousers and was honored as like you
know
best woman ceo or something like that so
playing both sides for the day when he
was in the pencil skirt one of the uh
difficulties for anyone to speak up
is that they're speaking out against
people they know and that's a big
component that i think a lot of people
should understand so i know many pro
skateboarders
for years i have been told by many pro
skateboarders they're upset with what's
happening they're upset with politics
many secretly support trump and they all
say but i cannot risk my livelihood to
speak out
and so exactly
don't don't don't come to me but i will
say i want to add something to this
uh there is an issue at play here and it
is a pro skateboarder that i have met
and skated with on a couple occasions
who's friends with people i know named
leo baker
uh leo baker is a is a um non-binary i
believe formerly i believe trans man and
before that was was a top female athlete
named lacey baker and i'm i i
i mean no disrespect but i have
questions and that question is
when leo was competing as a as a female
in the women's division as lacey baker
and winning
lacy transitions into in into leo
says that they're trans but continues to
compete against women
so my problem is
who is coming out and saying that taylor
silverman is wrong
when she says this why is it that a
biological male can just can say that
they now identify as a woman and compete
against women but a biological female
can say i am now trans but still compete
against women it's because everyone
knows that it's fake everyone is aware
of the lie and we're supposed to just
deal with the fact that we know it's a
lie and say something that is untrue
which is exactly what happens which is
literally what happens in the book 1984.
is that you're supposed to know that you
know you you believe you believe the
truth and you speak the lie and that is
the most dangerous aspect of this
what i want to add to sorry just
because uh when i saw this story i saw
colin wright's tweet that taylor spoke
out
that's uh look taylor is not somebody
who is a prominent pro skateboarder with
millions of followers who can risk
speaking out and
be rich these pro skateboarders who tell
me they can't speak out i'm like you own
how many houses you have how many
followers you'd lose half of them you'd
still be rich or at the very least you'd
be middle class well jk rowling speaks
out she's spoken she's said that she has
lost opportunities she keeps speaking
out she keeps act you know being active
for women's rights and i have the most
respect for that i have the utmost
respect for miss silverman here and i
hope that you know i hope that you guys
work out a great situation
um and that she's able to be you know
continue being successful in her chosen
path
we all know that it's unreasonable when
we saw leah thomas swimming in the pool
against women we could all see that it
was completely a total lie that this
person should be competing against these
much shorter much smaller much less
strong women and we were just supposed
to go along with it anyway and people
did and it's it's shocking to see that
and i think that the more this happens
and the more we see women athletes start
to speak out the more hopefully the tide
will shift on this and you know beth
steltzer who does save women sports
who's a really fascinating person who
saw this happen in weightlifting you
know she's been fierce and fighting on
this i think the thing you said there is
women and it needs to come from women
and that's why i think taylor may is so
commendable here because if it doesn't
come from women i mean men could bark
about this all they want but it's women
who are the victims and are missing the
opportunities because of this so they
unfortunately in our society need to be
the most vocal about it because people
don't like listening to men so i'll
address one with super chat and they're
saying that i complained that the
swimmers didn't speak up until after
they had lost so let's break this down
first
is tim biased yes obviously i'm a
skateboard i've been skateboarding for
for 23 years so of course this i see
this story and i'm like oh haram you
know how did they but there is a
difference with the ncaa they had been
consistently competing they knew it was
happening they knew it was going to
happen they had swam more than one time
there were multiple races
my understanding of this story having
dug into it and spoken with some people
involved when you go to a skateboarding
contest you don't know who you're
competing against you they say hey
there's going to be a contest in this
place at this time you go to a local
qualifier then you show up and all of a
sudden you see who you're competing
against my understanding is that this is
not an instance that's exactly the same
where this person
knew i'm going to fly to this place and
compete in this context against a trans
person it was they showed up and said
oh really now
fair criticism it did take taylor a few
months to speak out
and uh i think you know you need to
speak out sooner than that and and but
that's fine i mean look man um i can be
angry and critical and i i think the
fact that she was second place one cash
could have walked away with the cash not
as much cash as she wanted but instead
she's like no no no no i've got to say
something about this because the woman
who got bumped out of the the bracket
isn't speaking up like with the ncaa the
woman got bumped from the bracket was
the one who spoke out and i said you're
only speaking out because you you lost
the money well in this instance the
person who got bumped didn't speak out
the person who did get the money is the
one speaking out and i'm like okay but
but either way either way
um
i got to say i love you
i love that they came for your sport and
you were just like no that's it
i'm not doing it then they came for
skateboarding
for swimming and i said nothing because
i do not think that's not i i think
there's a fair element there absolutely
i think i think but i think that's great
i think that's great you know when you
see it happen in your own stuff i think
it really makes a big difference i saw
this happen in theater when suddenly um
grants that were because you know there
were grants like women's plays only
women should submit plays for this and
you know proposals and whatever and then
the
the granting opportunities and the
opportunities that had been specifically
for women were suddenly for women
or
self-identified women and i was like
what's this about this is not reasonable
you know it's not these this is not for
playwrights who are men in dresses this
is supposed to be for women playwrights
and
everything changed everything changed
very quickly and i that's why you know
that's in part why i started speaking
out about this because i found that so
infuriating and stupid it is infuriating
and it's not as if anyone could change
the the definition of woman like men and
women are different but i do find it
comical that women were never asked no
because only they were literally never
asked dudes started wearing dresses and
like this said that yeah we're women and
it's like do you have opinions about
that like yes they're like no you're not
allowed to like you're not allowed
imagine there was imagine a situation no
policy there was no there's no committee
imagine a situation where a six foot
tall man
in a dress with heels looks down at you
and says i'm a woman i'm a woman are you
gonna say otherwise you're like yeah i
know you're you're oh sure okay don't
don't hurt me mr crazy man we try to be
respectful to uh two people who are you
know we we we try to be respectful as i
mentioned uh often even ben shapiro said
he would use preferred pronouns in a
public setting because it's just easier
though he doesn't agree with it and
wouldn't use it in in
an academic or a journalistic setting
we we we are the
tolerant
we say i may not like it but you know
i'm in my own business you know you do
your thing and that's how gay marriage
comes to pass we're like okay look
you're gonna you're gonna get your tax
benefits you can go into your home you
can do your thing and then it's it's
funny because there's that meme
from 2000 and was it 2012 or something
or does it yeah i was like what happens
if gay marriage becomes legalized and
it's like world war iii will happen
people will start teaching kids about
about gay sacks and it's like and here
we are those things are happening that's
what's going down thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there